cal cuantro will be the northeast ohio
ford dealers starting pitcher for the
tribe tonight
and quattro owen two looking for that
first win be a good night for him to get
it
high fly ball to center field bradley
zimmer
with the breeze blowing in has an easy
play two down yeah wind might be your
friend today as a pitcher that's the
lineup that will face
mike miner who makes his second start
against the indians this year
bunning and he lays down a good one
dozier bare hands and throws
and
hernandez may have collided with
santana's left hand or wrist
carlos dropped the glove immediately
that's so dangerous we've seen that
injury happen to first baseman that are
right-handed
throws up the line in the runner's way
you're trying to catch the ball and he's
saying i want my glove i'm gonna stay in
here
miners one two is swung on and missed
good slider horror down and in slider to
the right-handed batter
ramiros hits it hard to dozier
royals getting out at second and they
turn a double play
because they can see players are more
fatigued
liner to right and harold ramirez
leaning down to make the catch for route
number two might have had some problems
seeing that ball or it could have been a
knuckle ball and he gets over there it
just rolls on the crowd sticks the glove
out and catches it
right in it
and now dozier hits it hard but he gets
that one over rosario so hunter is on
[ __ ] a lot of lefties are going to
throw that breaking ball and he messes
with it
good spot there with him
that's a fair ball
down the line
off the sidewall and big harold's going
to second base with a two out double
nice piece of hitting his 13th double of
the year
and look at him go up top and hit it on
the ground the other way
sends a high fly ball deep to left
center field taylor back and now coming
in makes the catch wind might have
knocked that one down eighth in the
lineup in left field the lefty mike
miners pitch swung on bang to third and
it's fair by the diving dozier down the
left field line kicks off the side wall
in standing with a double is mercado
he yanked it down that third base line
and that's his second two bagger
so the indians have three hits
but the first
time they've had a runner in scoring
position
bunning and he pops it up
not very high and salvi makes a diving
play
oh man that's an all-star catch if i've
seen one
way to come out of there you know ball
goes up you
everybody knows where it's going except
for the catcher everybody's yelling up
up he's trying to pick it up see where's
it going okay right here look at this
snow cones it
oh man look at that effort
mercado bolts for third pitch is not in
time and oscar has the steal
[Applause]
ground ball right to nikki lopez who has
to hurry and it is in time
his second full count but he's been
swinging a miss struck him out first k
for cuantro one down the pain i don't
see it
that's good
ben attendee that's a shot into right
field catch that one he is one for two
salvi hits that a mile
[Applause]
so he got a hanging slider and the
royals
strike first on a two-run home run by
salvador perez
his 21st slowed everything down didn't
jump
didn't over swing he just reacted to
a mistake in the middle
ding ding ding ding
salvador perez
paging salvador for the home run derby
said he had a practice round today yeah
there it was
double play ball here amid to cesar
on to bobby bradley to end the inning
again the o2
and a line drive into left field for the
franimal
jose stops at second try and get you to
hit his pitch
bradley lines it up the alley and left
center field
jose scores fran meal coming around
third tsar ball will wave him home nikki
lopez throw to the plate is in time and
he is out at the dish
the indians get one back it's now two to
one and bobby bradley's
in scoring position with one out yeah
now
i don't know if that's the chance they
wanted to take there with nobody out you
have to be pretty sure that you're going
to score on that
play right there with reyes running so
that's the first out down the right
field line for a double in his first hit
bat
and then he spanks one of the center
field bradley around third sarba this
side will hold him
would throw a good one all the way
toward home plate
[Applause]
mercado
three straight games now has two hits on
the night we are tied at two big
harold's going to third oscar headlong
into second base he took advantage of
the bubble by michael taylor
and the indians have second and third
with two down and it's a 2-2 ball game
boy i'll tell you what that's a nice job
of hitting with two outs look at taylor
he bobbled it and nonchalantly just let
mercado go to second base mercado didn't
waste any time hit a line drive to left
field and i love his hustle
[Applause]
right back up the middle it kicks off
minor
zimmer's going to be safe the indians
take the lead
big herald scoring on the play it's
three to two
and they've got first and third now with
two away
[Applause]
and he hits a high fly ball left center
field back is taylor looking up it is
gone to the bleachers
a sick spot in the fourth how about
another three run home run
two out three run homer by cesar
hernandez it's his 15th on the year and
his fourth home run in the last 13 games
and that
is a haymaker what an inning by the
indian a six five
one year in atlanta
up the middle jose ramirez there you go
the hit parade continues that's the 10th
hit of the night for the indians exactly
runner goes 3-2 ground ball base hit
left field jose is on his way to third
he'll go in without a throw rbi double
his last time up
[Applause]
and a ground ball to second merrifield
goes to second for one back to first
it's a double play the indians do get
another run and the lead is now seven to
two
[Music]
then attendee hits one into right center
field deep
and that will be gone for a sonic slam
nice
my goodness it's a good time to hit it
middle pitch right belt high just saying
saying hit me all over it good backspin
provided irvin santana gave up a run on
a double play ball last night
the pitch swung out blasted high deep to
left forget about it
roberto perez has hit his fifth home run
and the indians regain that five run
lead a towering blast to the bleachers
and left trying to get me up to speed on
what what's
there's a ball blister to deep left
field and it is off the wall
zimmer will score
ahmed in the second base safely with an
rbi double it's another two out run for
the indians and for ahmed rosario that
is his ninth double and 25th run batted
in on the year they're loaded with
nobody out
chopped out to bradley
he'll take the out that's all the
indians want right now the royals get
the run
left center field zimmer will run it
down the royals will get another run so
the fielder's choice in the air
leads to a run keeps the lower half
everything's in line
rolled and it's going to get by
hernandez and the royals will get
another run taylor comes down from third
and the royals have three in the seventh
inning oscar mercado to the plate
mercado sends a high fly ball deep left
field
goodbye baseball and a big home run for
oscar mercado wow
a three run homer second one of the game
for the indians and a four run seventh
inning as they blow it wide open now it
is the zimmer zimmer matchup bradley
zimmer hitting kyle zimmer his big
brother pitching and the one two and a
swing and a miss at a fastball down kyle
zimmer strikes out bradley zimmer for
the second out of the inning jose
ramirez one for three tonight
there's a drive deep right field
gone a home run for jose ramirez
the 2-2
there's a one-hopper i mean rosario has
it
book it the indians win their third
straight they wallop kansas city tonight
14-6